welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and thor love thunder just dropped
a new trailer promo with a ton of new
footage that i have to break down frame
by frame but not only that we got some
official photos from total film that
like everything in this movie are nearly
impossible to see because why would you
look at anything other than these
characters arms somehow somehow i
managed to avert my eyes for just a few
seconds at a time to other things in
that frame this process awakening
everything in me and i discovered some
new insights about love and thunder
including some mysterious teases from
the cast and crew in interviews let's
break it all down and let's start with
the new trailer that just dropped roll
the clip god's gone
get the popcorn out he's gonna do a
speech
see what's happening here
you're afraid
i'm scared oh oh no
anxious
my friends
times like this we need to unite come
together
i'm sorry me it's very hard to get a
rousing speech with the hate noise
oh god we're gonna die
this is my vow
oh god she will die
that seems a bit dangerous
this ends here and
now
marvel studios thor love and thunder oh
my god so much to talk about first we
got to talk about the speed with which
thor can summon stormbreaker as he
embarks upon this battle with the rest
of the guardians i love how we see his
mastery over stormbreaker setting up the
frustration this guy's gonna feel when
his original weapon mule near returns
but does not zip right to his hand the
way stormbreaker does cork clears a path
in that new asgard town hall meeting for
thor to come in and make his big speech
and a glorious here for the first time
we see olympus from the outside and it
is a floating city structure in the sky
a sun blazing behind it but clearly not
our sun our sun would be much brighter
this one we can actually see the orb
structure of this star and i love how
olympus evokes the structure of asgard
both are floating discs with structures
both above and below maybe i'm seeing
things but the structures in the top
half of olympus actually look burned
compared to the golden lower half and
the golden outer surfaces we might be
seeing someone fleeing olympus after the
attack from gore and what is departing
olympus here why that is thor's goat
boat the egger blasting away from it
carried by his two trusty goats and i
like how carrying this boat is a rainbow
showing how it is stormbreaker's bifrost
powers that are allowing it to transport
thor and mighty thor gene gaze upon new
asgard from a high point as it blazes
during this battle with the creatures
who we think are the black berserkers
who are symbiote-like amorphous beings
that emanate from all black the necker
sword disputes in the marvel comics all
black comes from the symbiote deity null
and even though a splash of venom is
left in the mcu currently i would just
be really surprised if the word symbiote
or venom or anything like that is
brought up in this movie and you can see
how a huge explosion blows some of these
creatures off of their feet or whatever
you call their appendages looks like the
explosion rocks a boat that's sitting on
a trailer maybe one of the other tourist
boats of this colony another shot of the
corpse of falagar the behemoth then a
close-up of a very scared looking korg
and then more of this fight with the
guards of olympus i like how they bleed
gold like the sovereign from guardians
vol 2 valkyrie licks some of this gold
blood off her sword and you can see the
rest of her body is covered in this
stuff i like how thor uses his chains
his whips and lassos to toss them around
his straddle using the battle ropes with
the chains of that giant skeleton are
clearly paying off here i just love how
jane releases the broken fragments of
mjolnir as a cluster spray which then
presumably retract into the hammer's
broken form an amazing new range attack
that only works if mjolnir is broken
into pieces like this now notice as korg
assists thor you can see our clearest
shot yet of the larger deities on the
thrones in the background one is in gold
carrying a staff having an interesting
headpiece another one to the right of it
dressed in red so we're seeing different
tiers of gods some the size of normal
humans some roughly 10 to 12 feet tall
and these larger ones look to be a mix
of humanoids with animalistic heads much
like the 10-foot tall egyptian gods like
amit khanshu and tower it who we met in
moon knight we also know there will be a
human form of bost eke bastet in these
seats and i am thinking that we will
also meet the maya deity of izamna
because i'm pretty sure this pantheon is
the council of godheads from the thor
comics which includes zeus itzamna
osiris whom we saw in moon knight but
also the celtic god of nuata the
iroquois spirit of manitou the russian
spirit of svarag and the aztec deity of
this i am awful at pronouncing aztec
terms i'm not even gonna try now the
maya deity i believe is gonna take the
form of a jaguar though to be clear it's
amna does not take the form of the
jaguar in the mayan mythology whoever
the mayan god or goddess is ultimately i
believe is going to be using namor the
submariner as an avatar the way bost
uses a black panther as an avatar and
the way kanshu uses moon knight as an
avatar something that we're gonna
explore a lot more in wakanda forever
it's also possible that they use a
different mayan dd than insomnia because
in my mythology the jaguar spirit is
considered to be zipalanke another name
that i very much apologize if i
mispronounced now if you look closely
the weapon that korg tosses the thor is
actually korg's trusty melee weapon that
he had on sakhar in ragnarok now in this
town hall thor passes the residents of
new asgard and i love how you can see
they've all assimilated into the fashion
styles of earth yet many of them still
bear the hairstyles and facial hair of
asgardians which i think could best be
described as like wren faire country
club week i love this behind him
valkyrie wears a phantom of the opera
shirt now we know this is a tourist
economy and it has a theater company
melissa mccarthy's be playing hella in a
restation of the events of ragnarok and
maybe like in las vegas they have a
resident production of phantom but like
in a convenient hour and a half version
of it behind them is someone wearing
traditional asgardian ware maybe the
actress in one of those plays who played
frigga but also in the shot you can see
how natalie portman has been made taller
with vfx because in real life she is not
a foot taller than tessa thompson as she
appears to be here and of course meek
wearing these secretarial clothes has
been impressively jotting down all this
dictation on the dry erase board but
doing it in this really cool kamala khan
style doodling i love how she plugged a
marker into her wrist appendage where a
blade normally is she also drew a really
impressive depiction of asgard but one
of the more confusing shots of this
footage shows an insane battle with the
guardians in this jungle setting you see
drax and kraglin as well as nebula and
then rocket floating in on his jet pack
in the background and then i assume
groot is somewhere around here fighting
in this water against beasts with
tentacles that yeah do look a lot like
the black berserker creatures that are
attacking new asgard drax uses his
dagger to cut off a piece of it there is
some other species in this water setting
they have shells kind of like turtles or
crabs to me they kind of look like water
armadillos and the jungle behind them is
some kind of industrial looking
deforestation process i don't know maybe
this is part of the act one montage when
thor and the guardians fight in a series
of battles on various landscapes aiding
various societies across the galaxy
basically we're seeing the asgardians of
the galaxy in action and it looks
awesome then very interesting shot here
we have to talk about thor will also
appear in this chamber that contains the
statues of the cosmic entities we
identified the living tribunal statues
directly behind him the watcher on the
left of that and then we know on the
other side of this room based on the
shots of jane that we're also going to
see the statue of lady death in eon and
infinity now before i pointed out how
the living tribunal's faces are
different in various shots one the half
covered face when the fully uncovered
face indicating to me that the head
might rotate as opposed to just being
fixed in place and that these statues
might have more life to them some of you
said i was crazy but no no no now when
you go frame by frame through this shot
of thor you can definitely see the
living tribunal head rotating slightly
behind him so yeah jane and thor are
gonna have an active dialogue with these
statues we may even hear the voice of
jeffrey wright as uwatu the watcher in
the statue form but notice to the right
of thor in this shot some bricks are
crumbled behind him i wonder if there
could have been a sixth entity in this
room whose statue was destroyed now if
infinity is at the far end maybe across
the diagonal here would be her brother
eternity eternity might be being
destroyed as a way of showing how the
multiverse is currently crumbling
through a series of incursions leading
to avengers secret wars thank you reed
richards for giving us the word
incursions we see the same shots of gore
the god butcher with christian bale's
head unscarred in one shot but then
presumably later on in the film later on
in his life definitely scarred up he may
be making his vow in a flashback here
when he was younger to his dying wife
ara or their starving son agar maybe
he's making his vow to the first god he
killed from whom he took the sword by
the way i still love the theory that i
mentioned in past videos that gore might
have come from vormir vormir could have
been his homeworld he could have had
some history with the soul stone even
though i guess that does feel a bit
unlikely to be revealed in this film i
still pray to the gods i could be right
on that probably not then korg and
mantis and thor on the benatar ship
mantis's hair looking greener here then
we get this gnarly shot of thor leading
the guardians through some fire mantis
rocket craglin peter quill star-lord
nebula groot and drax but notice how
thor here is still a bit chubby he's got
that viking beard and the same exact
armor that he had in the final battle of
end game this is likely the first battle
that the asgardians of the galaxy had
together after they left earth before he
lost all of his weight in that training
montage then thor confronts gore in this
desaturated setting only his eyes
glowing the color of mjolnir's blue
lightning i theorize that gore and his
sword are actively desaturating the
universe because the spectrum of color
in the mcu comes from the infinity
stones and from infinity herself and
despite the stone's atomization that
radiation continues to course through
the universe so by killing these gods
gore might be depriving the universe of
its color fading it into grey tones
behind thor some blurry shots of some
giant crab-like creatures maybe the same
snakey vines that gore pushes through in
other shots which could be the black
berserker's final forms and as their
weapons collide sparks of color begin to
burst out of the impact i presume this
is gonna result in that vibrant neon
shot from the other promo but big
announcement coming your way the team at
epic hero shop is releasing their god
butcher world tour design early it looks
awesome inspired by heavy metal concept
graphics from the 80s this design
features a necro sword skewering the
head of the norse god of thunder thor
kabob anybody the tour stops include
realms gore visited in the comics and
places he might hit in the movie some
great easter eggs that you can wear
anywhere you can get this unique design
on a premium fit t-shirt or wall poster
they've also got thor's strongest
avenger hats back in stock perfect for
showing off at any barbecue or pool
party this summer grab these designs and
mark your calendars because july 7th we
are dropping a new latest obsession to
celebrate the release of thor love and
thunder in theaters and of course don't
forget about the
noober
and miss marvel collections mondolani if
you are watching we've got a shirt for
you just let us know we would be honored
if you ever wore it and for all of you
do not miss out on those latest
obsession designs before they are gone
we love working with epic hero shop
because of their attention to detail
their awesome products and their great
customer service shop these designs and
more at epicheroshop.com
and we end this trailer with one new
line from gore how exciting which is the
most personality we've really seen from
his character so far and you get the
sense that christian bale might be
taking some elements from his dark
knight co-star heath ledger when it
comes to the energy he's bringing to
gore the giddy laugh he has here the
line this is my vow all gods will die
definitely folks starting tonight people
will die i'm a man of my word you can't
blame christian bale at all because the
mcu deserves a higher class of criminal
why not take inspiration from the best
but we have to move on to the new photos
that were released and these interview
quotes with the cast and crew because
those tell us quite a bit and gave me a
wild take for how this movie could end
so total film released three official
photos the first confirms what i spotted
in the second trailer last month that
thor's meditation atop that peak with
the wisdom tree will be interrupted by
two of the guardians now confirmed to be
peter quill in mantis now mantis's
appearance has changed somewhat a
brighter shade of green in her hair are
not in this photo the oversized darker
peepers that she had before though this
might just be mantis before the film's
post-production has adjusted the vfx on
her eyes will bring mantis up here makes
some sense because as an empath she can
sense thor's emotions and thor is going
through something of an identity crisis
in this film and mantis's empathy might
help thor in this soul-searching or at
least wake him up out of his meditative
trance so that he can help them in this
fight like how she woke him up in
infinity war
there's also a new image of natalie
portman as the mighty thor jane foster
standing in that same new asgard town
hall meeting room where the rest of the
residents have gathered in the aftermath
of the attack of those beasts that we
assume are gore's black berserkers kevin
feige said in this interview with the
magazine that jane's bulked-up
appearance was mostly portman's doing
saying quote the only thing we assisted
with was making the mighty thor a little
bit taller that was the only movie magic
we used everything else was all her but
then this third photo shows thor on the
benatar the guardians of the galaxy's
ship he's wearing the outfit that we've
talked about before the one that overall
looks like kurt russell in big trouble
in little china he's also got that
studded version of quill's red jacket
with the sleeves torn off and it's tank
with an interesting design i assume an
artistic rendition of the yitra so
world's tree and now you can see more
clearly in the branches of that tree the
same asgardian pattern that the bifrost
would leave burned into the grass but
now i'm pretty curious about this green
plant specimen in the glowing chamber in
the background the benatar has been seen
to have plants kept on it in infinity
war there was a cactus looking plant in
the background between gamora and drax
drax here allowing himself to be visible
i think you can also see the same plant
on the ship in endgame when tony and
nebula were stranded on the benatar the
shot where they were fixing the ship to
stretch out its life support capacity to
23 days we also know the guardians kept
fresh veggies of the yarrow root on
their patch ship the milano and
guardians volume 2. i'm hungry can we
say that yara
no it's not ripe yet and i hate you
it's not ripe but in endgame since tony
and nebula were starving to death for
over three weeks if this was a yarrow
root plant that they were growing on
board it either is not ripe here or it's
some other plant that just is not edible
and remember in the second episode of
what if we learned of an interesting
flora specimen that the guardians of the
galaxy were interested in called the
ember of genesis nutrient-rich cosmic
dust from an ancient supernova with the
power to terraform entire ecosystems
with one ounce you can heal a dying
planet in minutes and ever since then i
have been hoping that the ember of
genesis could make its way into live
action who knows maybe that is something
the guardians could gift to the zatoyan
people of satari for yondu's home tribe
maybe even the ember of genesis was
something the eternals used to gift the
early sumerians the gift of agriculture
like the guardians on their ship the
eternals had a kind of greenhouse that
it looked like ajax was using to grow
all kinds of [ __ ] like i spotted some
space indica in there anyway you can add
all of this to my series of ridiculous
gastronomic queries we've explored on
this channel including what is thanos
cooking and giant dumps
now in addition to these updates we
learned from an interview with taika
with tt chris hemsworth and tessa
thompson by vendego's jacqueline coley
in which thompson revealed that valkyrie
doesn't necessarily cross paths with the
guardians in this movie i just came to
set to watch because i wasn't in any of
the guardian stuff and i don't remember
which of them said it to me but someone
asked me is it always like this
i was like yes it is ah this further
confirms what we have suspected that
thor's time with the guardians hopping
from planet to planet will really be in
the movie's first act but when thor
returns to earth that will begin his
time with jane and with valkyrie now of
course just because tessa thompson
didn't share a set with the guardians
doesn't mean that she won't be in any
scenes with them because elizabeth olsen
confirmed her scenes with the illuminati
multiverse of madness were really her
alone on a blue screen set and she's
never actually met john krasinski these
wizards at marvel can pull off anything
but these three were also asked about
the deeper meaning of the title of love
and thunder there is love in this film
across the board everyone has a little
awakening in
one way or another some shape or form
universal love and love for one self
want love for friends one for universe
love for and you know universal love huh
and i find it interesting that as
hemsworth began to say this taika otiti
jumped in interrupting him to clarify
love for and you know it looks like you
know that you can assume some things
from the title but also don't assume
yeah that's tv that's true
i like that that just means that we
don't know what we're talking about and
then this led to an interesting back and
forth about the way the movie ends
is different than what you might think
it's a romance a romantic comedy it's a
romance it's a comedy it's a romance
romantic comedy tragedy it's a dramatic
and then later in the interview taika
with titi when pressed finally cited
which romance film influenced him
obviously it was about like things that
were like officer and a gentleman like
particularly the end scene where he
comes in and sweeps her off her feet so
what the hell are they getting at well
we will find out soon i can't wait to
revisit this interview on the other side
of the movie but taekwondo went on to
say that when he pitched this movie he
imagined the cover of a mills and boone
romance novel which definitely explains
that trailer shot of thor chest exposed
on the deck of a pirate ship and why ttd
and thompson seem to suggest that
despite the love in the movie's title
and initial premise the way this movie
ends might be a sort of antithesis to
the classical romantic notions of
chivalry giving up everything for one's
soul mate that this movie leads with
which is essentially the story beats
that we saw at the ends of spider-man no
we home and doctor strange with
multiverse of madness that classic
notion of if you love them let them go
and i'll say as much of a trope as it is
anytime i see that in a movie my heart
melts but that is not the kind of
filmmaker taika watiti is he loves to
subvert expectations he loves to burn
the world down at the end of his movies
that's what he did in thor ragnarok
nothing is sacred in that movie asgard's
not a place it's a people i'm assuming
he's gonna do the same thing in love and
thunder instead of what we expect an
implication that thor and jane will
always love each other but it's best
that they part ways you might just say
they were never right for each other but
tt is not very kind about the way jane
is depicted in the first two thor movies
i think he's gonna retroactively say
that the love that they had for each
other was not pure and true in any form
and in fact when you go back and watch
those movies the thing that they were
actually in love with was what chris
hemsworth was hinting at the universe a
universal love the moment jane fell for
thor was beside that campfire as he
explained teacher cell in the nine
realms she's an astrophysicist and thor
for her embodied the cosmos he was a sky
full of stars encased in a sexy bod you
can't blame her for falling for him
because he fell from the stars so how
interesting is it now that this film is
also introducing corporeal forms of
abstract heavenly concepts like infinity
infinity is a sister to eternity and the
two of them together embody the known
universe a sky full of stars encased in
a sexy bod so i don't know i am totally
reaching here but maybe jane will end
this movie falling in love with infinity
swept off her feet like debra winger in
an officer and a gentleman carried away
into the cosmos and knowing what jane
goes through in the mighty thor jason
aaron comics an image that might bring
tears to her eyes because like all
asgardians when they die doesn't it make
sense for her to be lifted off of this
cosmic plane into a higher one time will
tell but the meantime you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at a boss
follow new rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you